So this is part 5 of my series about how was
my experience giving birth here in the Netherlands.
When I share with people that Maria
was born at 1:36 in the morning
and that 4:00am we were home already,
the majority of the reactions that I get is just shock.
So I wanted to share how long
usually after giving birth
you leave the hospital
basically if you choose to have a hospital birth.
So if you have option 1 like me,
just a natural labour,
no complications at all,
mum and baby are doing just fine,
you probably will be discharged within 3 hours.
So basically
Maria was born at 1:36.
We spent around an hour and a half in our golden hour
breastfeeding,
bonding, uh, the late card clamp and all that.
And then after that
the nurse came in and she was like, okay,
you can take a shower now and also pee.
After you do those two things,
you then can go home.
If you have a C section,
of course, it's a major surgery
so you will stay in the hospital for long,
usually three days.
Um, and basically that's it.
You're gonna then be ready to go home.
What happens?
A lot of people like, oh my god,
you went back home in the middle of the night.
Yes, we did. I heard about stories,
several actually
of mums that gave birth during the night.
They didn't feel safe
or they just didn't want To go home so fast.
So they have asked to the hospital
if they could stay a little longer until the morning.
Usually if the hospital has a room available for you,
if they're not full,
if it's not super busy day for them,
they will say yes
and they will allow you to stay.
But if it's full,
if they are too busy
under staff,
they will likely say no.
I didn't ask because I didn't feel the need to do so.
But I also know that the hospital was full that day.
So probably the answer would be just no.
And then after leaving the hospital,
you can just go home,
take your car,
a taxi, whatever.
You do have to have the baby in the car seat,
of course. They will not let you go without it.
And I heard stories about people that
they gave birth during the day, morning,
so they just took the tram home,
they walk at home.
So yeah, whatever
you feel comfortable
and it's safe for you and for your baby.